so we're told consider the formula y is
equal to 2c over p where
y represents the carat yield so
y represents the carat yield
c
represents the number of expected
carrots
and p represents the number of plants
so p
represents the number of plants select
an appropriate measurement unit for
carrot yield
so the key here is to realize that we
can treat units
like we would treat algebraic variables
and so for example over here if we if
we're saying our yield is going to be
two times the number
the number of expected carats divided by
the number of plants
well our units
our units are going to be well actually
we could we could put some put some
numbers in here actually just to make
something more interesting let's just
say that c
is equal to
10 carats
and i'm just making these numbers up
just hopefully it makes sense what i'm
about to do
and let's say that p
is equal to
i don't know 30 plants
p is equal to 30 plants and so using
this formula y
y
would be equal to
times
10 carats 2 times
carats
divided by
p which for this case is 30 plants
30 plants
and so 2 times 10 carats that's going to
be 20 carats
so we can write the numerator as this is
20 carats divided by 30 plants and so
that is going to be equal to you could
divide the numbers so it would be 20
divided by 30 which would be two-thirds
two-thirds and then the units would be
carrots per plant
two-thirds carrots per plant
carrots
per
plant
carrots per
plant and once again the whole point of
what i just did is to see what the units
would be for our carat yield and we can
see the units would be carrots
per plant and i put the numbers there
just hopefully it makes a little bit of
intuitive sense of what we just did that
we're algebraically manip as we
algebraically manipulate or
mathematically manipulate the numbers we
do the same thing with the units and so
when we try to find the appropriate
measure unit for carrot yield which i
had never heard of before this video we
see it's carrots per plant is the
appropriate measurement unit not carrots
per plant squared that would have been
the case if we were squaring this p over
here or plants times the square root of
carats well that would be more so we're
taking the square root up here and we
weren't dividing by p but we were
multiplying by p but the general theme
that you could see is this constant this
2 didn't affect what happens to the
units but what did matter is how these
variables relate to each other we're
taking the variable c dividing it by p
so whatever the units were for c we
divide those units by the units for p
and we get the units for yield carats
per plant